any other artists out of Vegas that
you're [__] with that we should know
about that maybe we don't know about yet
man yeah it's a couple
Tay bands is one of them he's hot he's
super hot he's about the ladies and
stuff like that
um you got 20g he's hot
if I can get him to stop set tripping so
much man
um pop out
hot man
um two times this is my boy right there
we got some Classics together
um and these are artists that are coming
out like now right now yeah so it's a
couple of them man forgive me if I don't
name you but um we both
it's a mortise out there some new Young
coming up how you mentioned said
tripping how how different is the
culture on and the Gang [__] in Vegas
compared to a place like la
um
other than it being really smaller you
know what I'm saying
um
I don't know man I think it's just like
you know you got real dudes everywhere
other than like you know Vegas got their
own you know certain gangs and stuff
like that
so but um
man I think it's kind of like
it's kind of like the same really man
you know they just gotta um a lot of
people out there doing a lot of dissing
and stuff like that you know what I'm
saying like right in the music yeah and
it's kind of it's kind of a [__] up
thing man
um
because the police are all over it and
they don't understand that yeah you know
what I'm saying like people really be
telling on their stuff nowadays well I
from what I understand Metro has like a
a list of rappers they do I'm I'm on
that list yeah the list is I can't Las
Vegas Metro you there's a list of
artists who can't perform right
I know mozzy's on the list I think YG
was on the list he might have been
Nipsey was on the list at a certain
point in time [__] I've been on the list
for a minute they've been uh they've
been [__] with me for a while to the
point where they even told one promoter
they were going to put a DUI checkpoint
in the parking lot Jesus yeah and I've
never had an issue with no show and
Metro sucks man never had an issue I
think Metro might be the worst Police
Department I've ever like lived in a
place and had to deal with yeah like
I've actually gotten pulled out of a car
shaken down money taken off of me all
right you can go angle line they got a
different type of attitude they're
[__] bro my boy DJ Sam I Am one time
outside of uh koi where I Planet
Hollywood we're leaving bro these cops
[__] this dude up threw them in the
back of the Paddy Wagon chip both his
[__] teeth for nothing it was crazy
bro it was like the Vegas Police are
[__] insane yeah they crazy man I
didn't boy boy I can tell you some
stories
they raided my house one time and ended
up taking me to jail for a parking
ticket
it's some like Mafia [__] yeah we don't
like you so we go yeah they came to the
house he didn't find nothing he told me
I said man what's this one he said man
he had like a list full of stuff on
there Molly Coke everything every drug
you could name was on the list and I was
like man I know that here
if we looked me dead in my face he was
like I know you don't got no drugs here
I know you're smarter than that he said
but I know you carry it down
like that's all I want to find because
you know my first
distribution weapon size you know if I
could call another gun it's like over
it's a problem you know what I'm saying
so um
I was like man y'all know again and he
was like yeah you do he's like every
gangster got a gun man they searched
that house for about two and a half
hours okay they find a gun I didn't have
one in there right it was crazy is um
you know that's how I know you know
there's definitely a man upstairs I did
have some in the house like 48 hours
prior and my homeboy and my cousin was
like get this [__] out of here I was
like why it was like a duffel bag and
they was like I was like man don't
nobody be over here and my dude was like
that's why you don't need him in the
house
so I had somebody pick him up and take
him out the house two days later the
police ready Jesus yeah
parking ticket when I got in there the
dude was like um you ain't supposed to
be in here for this I was like yeah I
know he said well why are you here I
said they raided my house he said you
must have been clean huh I was like yeah
he came in there for like two hours and
let me go that's so [__] crazy
just like we just we've decided we're
taking you to jail today but we're gonna
find a reason yeah that's [__] insane
damn well you've moved on to greener
pastures oh yeah yeah I'm cool man doing
the rap [__] it ain't no chasing no cars
in jail man I'm cool on that any other
uh likes are you are you got any other
businesses going on or
um right now just the movies man I've
been I've been really heavy like I did
those couple movies and you know that's
really
it's really beneficial you know what I'm
saying like super super so I've been um
I'm trying to do my own so we're not
trying to infinite do my own bankroll
the whole thing filming the whole thing
that'll be hard
well look be on the lookout new project
April 20 28th problematic problematic
for you yeah
crazy to us uh you all know why I call
it that once you listen to it you got a
features or anything no I don't it's on
me oh wait dang I do sorry the kid oh
he's dope I guess I really could yeah
he's hard I guess I really kid on there
we got we got a song on there that's
crazy too it's super hard yeah that's my
guy man we gotta we got like four or
five songs out already that's my dude
well I appreciate you pulling up man and
I appreciate you having me new music go
watch the freestyle
uh yeah man keep doing your thing man
what's up man appreciate it bro of
course brother you already know oh man
boom